dude take the hand it's weak for the
masked singer and we have a bone to pick
with one of the celebrities plus we'll
run down the five new clue packages we
saw hi guys I'm Charlie okay and I'm
Jesse Goddard like you said the
competition got too spooky for one
contestant and the skeleton was sent
back to the grave let's take a look at
the latest elimination
[Music]
[Applause]
okay when I heard Jenny McCarthy scream
second fiddle that was the second I knew
it was Paul Shaffer Paul Shaffer I think
the clues last week actually gave it
away even more I mean tonight we saw the
one about the orchestra clearly on david
letterman show he was second fiddle to
david letterman and also conducted the
orchestra what kind of gave it away for
you I honestly think it was his song
choice there was like a little bit when
he did rapper's delight' and the first
one is like a speak song whose kind of
rapping throughout the entire thing and
I was like oh my kind of you know
there's videos of him rapping so we were
able to find some of that but then on
his second song choice it really sold me
he sung blues before on the show and
then plus the rapping and then the grass
but I was like yes Paul Shaffer Paul
Shaffer and they actually guessed it
right which I thought was great two out
of the four judges yes got another one
right there doing greatness season so
you are they are and over on Twitter
it's anybody's guess here's what you
guys had to say at pint-sized oh four
tweet it fairly certain the skeleton is
Dana Carvey which Deidre and I actually
guest on the first week we saw him
perform oh okay well I didn't see that
one coming but I'm glad you two guessed
it the other way and at the real I hurt
tweeted well Dan the skeleton could be
anyone now center well now we know it's
mostly the skeleton may be gone but
there's still five more performers to
talk about our first of the night being
the Flamingo you know a flamingo may
stand on one leg but anyone with two
eyes can see there's certainly one
cheetah girl hunting behind this voice
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not having it's a Cheetah Girl I
won't take well honestly I got it
from the Triple Threat answer clue
because it's clearly a 3lw reference
thank you miss Adrienne Houghton and
she's of course a triple threat she can
sing dance act and Jenny Jenny McCarthy
is on a roll this is she got it right I
mean she'd guess we don't know if it's
right but we're with her on it and also
one of the flamingo clues that actually
gave it away from me she said after the
performance that when she was a kid she
wanted to be a doctor and even trained
at a medical school well we are pulling
the CVS receipts again Adrianna went to
high school for Health Professions and
Human Services in New York but obviously
she can't pursue a career in health okay
well now that we got the receipts
checked here um my clue that gave it
away was the wizard plucked her you know
at one day in her life and she actually
which I think this was earned could be
Ricky Martin there's a few other guesses
out there but he discovered her when she
was performing in a church choir in
Madison Square Garden
interesting that is my receipt right
there you know what but you know she's a
light lyric soprano okay so what we saw
from her sucker performance and from her
footless performances were this much
more mature sound than were used to with
like the Chanel Cheetah Girls sound
right but at the same time Karen there
you heard that classic Adrienne Houghton
vibrato and I was like this is hard
Twitter was agreeing with us you guys
had a field day at Lisa to the rescue to
tweet it bro Adrienne must think we are
stupid AF she is the flying out and
Michaela x3 tweeted you can't tell me
that the Flamingo is an Adrienne Bailon
after that performance and yes we agree
we are all in agreement here and while
we think we have the Flamingo figured
out we can't quite spot who's under the
leopard mask check out this next
performance
[Music]
okay so I know we were a little bit
confused about this one but I'm finally
sold on another than a kiss from a rose
seal and he was born in 1963 which we
saw on the door in the clue package and
he also said he was born not always
wanted and he was raised by a foster
family and none other than London the
judges are still set on other people
which is what's throwing me a bit
Nicole's still sat on Billy Porter she
said it two weeks ago she said it again
tonight jenny is thinking famous drag
queens
I'm not feeling RuPaul Billy Porter any
of those I'm really stuck on Selah
because of that voice and how deep it is
yeah I hear you there honestly and get a
root pump I'm from there and like she'll
see us at classic like little grasp in
its like low tar smooth but a baritone
going on and you know it only a good
singer can sing somebody to love and do
justice by Freddie Mercury I'm honestly
surprised judges do not hear that and
one other thing that gave it away fur
seal being my guess the post performance
clue they were really selling me tonight
I think those post performance clues
when they talk to the judges a bit were
really giving us better clues than the
clue packages actually they said they
served fast food and have an engineering
background which are the two broadest
range of things you could possibly say
with a little digging we did find out
that steel actually worked at McDonald's
briefly since you also worked in
electrical engineering that's enough to
tell me it's seal yes and apparently
that McDonald stint did not last too
long it was clogged enough to get a
paycheck so you know he took a little
bit but that clue technically was
accurate so over on the internet you
guys are actually picking this up as
well so at arrival the maus tweeted
starting to think seal is the leopard
we're in agreement there and at the lady
tie fling tweeted NPH girl please that
was one of the judges guesses Neil
Patrick Harris is not under that mask at
least I don't think so and Twitter
agrees no no no no but our next singer
had us searching the worldwide web web
web for answers take a look at the black
widows
[Music]
[Music]
hmm what are you thinking
this is absolutely raven symone there's
no question about it I mean Robin
guessed it as well yeah well he's right
and we're gonna back him up on that what
gave it away for you honestly I'm gonna
talk all about vocals tonight because
she was like checking up all my CVS
receipts tonight the first week
performance she did okay I want to dance
with somebody and thank you so much
because my favorite favorite karaoke
song to sing is that something you said
yes she did but if that one was like a
little bit in her lower range and she
still so like hit those high notes so at
first she looked kind of went low to
high and then tonight when she did
before he cheats she was in her head
voice at the beginning and when I turned
to you you were like I was like it
doesn't sound like bad came back from
that chorus and it sold it for me it was
the one because she pulled it out and
you know what the thing is it kind of
reminds me of the way that age I mean
the way that Raven uses her speaking
voice yeah when you hear her talking on
that so Raven or you know bravin's home
she's gonna be sweet you know buttery
voice and then everyone should pulls out
you know you're nasty
nasty right so she's got that like
grovel to her boys but she can also see
these light sweet notes so I'm gonna go
ahead and based on comparing it to her
sweet talking voice that is comparing
into her beautiful range and again for
me it was obviously the vocals that you
defined it as well but the post
performance clue once again this time we
heard her say I never went to prom but I
pretended to well yet again we are
pulling the received here and we
actually have a clip of leavin saying
that she never went to prom in real life
but did on TV take a look I did not get
to go to prom but I did a movie about a
prom
well over on Twitter people were
agreeing with us yes they were at fly
gray streak tweeted here comes the other
Cheetah Girl hey Raven and at simply C
tweeted oh I'll put bread
yes bread that Raven Symone is the Black
Widow both Cheetah Girls in one show I
love it and girls I've been doing way
too much singing I'm sorry that's why
you're here that's why I'm here okay
whatever I've said it once and I will
gladly say it again I am still think I'm
a shucks at our next performer we're
gonna take a look buck
the rain and wind stopped blowing but
you're stuck out in the same old storm
again
my god smooth dreamy vocals happening
here I just love you so much okay who do
we thinks the thingamajig is so the
first week we saw him sing and Deidre
and I were sad Wayne Brady and then the
internet told us we were very wrong
because because it's not Wayne Brady
anymore guys
the post performance clue is actually
what gave it away again for me with this
one we saw the thingamajig say my
darkest moment was when I went to rehab
well Victor actually went to rehab in
March of 2019 for a ruptured quad tendon
in his right knee which I think was a
little trick for us to figure that one
out okay yeah you got the the double
meaning the double right now yeah I
think you were getting a lot from that
final clue but the packages were still
like spot-on so because he's holding the
three dolls and I know family's super
important to him so I was thinking that
to be like his three sisters and
actually one of them is his twin sister
so you know I kind of found a lot from
that but over to the Internet at its
Miller time tweeted thingamajig is 100%
Victor Oladipo and we would totally
agree with you there and at flan TKE
tweeted is anyone else really hoping
thingamajig is Dennis Rodman just so
Jenny McCarthy has to shave her head yes
we all are okay yeah here for that and
lastly the butterfly has us saying a
certain name after tonight's performance
she has wings and she sings take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you think this is Michelle
Williams she's referenced so many times
throughout this and actually makes me a
little emotional because she says that
she's been waiting in her cocoon she has
this rebirth she's spent time you know
waiting for this kind of moment and
Michelle Williams opened up about
checking into a mental health facility
in 2018 actually so this kind of seems
like the perfect optic topper tunity for
a rebirth for her so I mean this part of
the clue package has always kind of
gotten me and has really led me to
thinking for sure Williams but on top of
that there was definitely another clue
that got her has thinking I mean I could
only think of one girl group who could
have a saying in her name that often
Destiny's Child
I mean sold for me I'm convinced it's
Michelle oh yes you can just hear it it
sounds like her she's got that classic
like Michelle Pfeiffer out of going on
for range is huge and there were a few
other things in the clue package
actually we saw it break up something
having to do with a lost past
relationship in December of 2018
Michelle and her ex Chad Johnson
actually ended their engagement so I
thought that was a big part of it she's
gone through a lot but Twitter had some
things to say as well and Jenn tsunami
tweeted amanda Bynes not feeling that I
don't know the man abides been sing like
that but also a source actually tells a
tee that Amanda Bynes turned down
Dancing with the Stars because it's not
the type of comeback she's looking for
which makes me think she probably
wouldn't do the mass singer either right
and Mel orell tweeted Michelle Williams
ain't nobody off with the London
backdrop I agree and I looked into that
one actually because London Michelle she
hasn't lived there for long I couldn't
find anything on any website but the
former Destiny's Child singer actually
did make her London stage debut as Roxie
Hart in for six weeks which counts he
had to come in exactly she did it well
we've officially said goodbye to five
contestants but there are still plenty
more to on masters how much to talk
about and we're gonna be talking about
it right here so post a comment below
with their best and well craziest
serious and just tweet us so we can
really talk all about it together
you know could end up on the show so I'm
at Jesse Goddard 18 and I'm at Charles E
O'Keefe we'll see you next time